or now on North Korea saying it's
restarted its nuclear facilities and
it's now working to improve its nuclear
weapons earlier we spoke to dr. Robert
Kelly professor of international
relations at depuy San National
University we are seeing what the North
Koreans were hoping to achieve well
there was a sort of big discussion in
the last a month and a half after the
landmine attack in August about
improving relations with North and South
Korea on between the two of them but the
president of South Korean held a pretty
tough line during those debates and
during the landmine incident this is my
guesses this is a way for the North
Koreans sort of prove that you know they
were not sort of face down in that
conflict and that they still have the
pride and dignity and everything else
and they're signaling to the rest of the
world that there's still a nuclear power
and that therefore if you want to
discuss that you have to offer something
really substantial the South did not in
the debate so the South didn't really
offer anything they didn't offer any
major concession so nuclear weapons is a
way to squeeze this up the North Korean
satellite launch is anything genuine
come the North has argued in the past is
planned in the past that has a space
program I don't think anyone in the
analyst community really believes that
most of us think that that is cover for
testing basic probably an ICBM
long-range weapons but some kind of
testing for you know for long-range
rockets it's probably like we've heard
this before that baby USS hostile and he
goes pursues honest whole policy the
North Koreans been saying that for
literally for decades I wouldn't read
anything about that other than the
typical need for the North Koreans again
to prove to their domestic audience why
North Koreans are sacrificing so much
right as long as North Korea is on a
permanent war footing as long as
foreigners ought to get North Korea an
American invasion is imminent and things
like that right you can justify why
North Korea so millet eyes militarize
you can justify the police state you can
justify all the privations why you know
the large number of people on the verge
of malnutrition on a regular basis